so today we received a little treat
because we got our first look at Shazam
Entertainment Weekly has been so kind to
provide us with this as they have done
in the past with Aquaman Avengers
infinity war and other DC and Marvel
films this first official photo shows
our hero getting some soda with his
buddy Freddy FEMEN for those of you who
aren't too familiar with Shazam although
he is a very powerful superhero much
like Superman and he does look like a
grown man
it's actually a fourteen-year-old boy
that's right Shazam is actually a
fourteen-year-old boy named Billy Batson
who has the powers to turn into Shazam
by saying his name Billy was gifted
these powers by a wizard who was looking
for a successor to inherit his powers
Billy happened to be in the right place
at the right time when he met this
wizard on the subway and was chosen so
even though it looks like a grown man
it's actually a 14 year old boy and
which is why she's AM is supposed to be
funny so let's take a look at Shazam in
this photo so for starters Zachary Levi
did buff up a lot for this character but
in this picture it still seems like they
Pat it a lot which makes sense because
Shazam is a pretty buff character so
they need to make him look the part
speaking of looking the part let's take
a look at the costume they're getting a
little away from the comics and going
more with the animated version of Shazam
and what I mean by that is it's not a
huge lightning bolt like you see in the
comics that takes up like the top half
of his body but it's more of an upside
down triangle with a very large and wide
a lightning bolt that's inside of it and
they also gave him a shorter cape fans
seem to be kind of divided on the look I
personally prefer the old comic book
look more than this but here's what
director David F Samberg had to say
about this I wanted to keep the shorter
cape as a throwback to the original
because that's something that sets him
apart from Superman or Batman it makes
him feel a bit more Golden Age superhero
which is the vibe I'm going for so hey
this is the look that the director is
going for and even though I would have
preferred the classic lightning bolt on
the front I still think it looks pretty
cool it really seems like DC
trying to step up their game Aquaman
looks like it's gonna be pretty good
it's been rumored to be really good for
those who have seen a few brief clips of
it and Shazam looks like it might be
pretty good as well
but let me know what you all think of
this first official look at Shazam hit
me with your thoughts in the comments
below and of course be sure to like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can stay up to date on Shazam
Aquaman all things DC Marvel and
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]